while the golden knights open their
fifth season right here in las vegas
yeah the nhl did a really cool thing by
matching up the two expansion teams and
sports director chris matthews joining
us now with more on this historic
matchup chris yeah they really couldn't
do it any other way that's you got to
get the two expansion teams tonight here
in las vegas nine had a different feel
to it these games count from now on
until they crown a champion uh later on
this summer you could feel the energy in
the building this season they got the
fans excited this really cool pregame
show a giant cracking on the ice look at
this the golden knight comes in he slays
the big sea monster you can see the
knights skate up from the center logo
yeah the whole thing burns up that's the
crack and pretty cool stuff there in
vegas they get off the blocks jumping
out to a 3-0 lead max patcher ready
scoring two of those goals knights have
never lost a game in franchise history
with a three-goal lead and they don't
tonight seattle made it fun they tied
the game at three but chandler stevenson
deflects in the goal off his skate vegas
wins the opener 4-3 the final robin
leonard gets his first win of the season
and for vegas it's their third straight
season opening win i thought it was
critical for us to get out to the lead i
thought
you know we had opportunities to really
extend that lead and put that game away
in the middle portion there hit some
crossbars
missed some chances to do that and let
them hang around a little bit but found
a way to win
once again it was packed out there
tonight the golden knights improved in
91 0 and 1 when leading by at least
three goals in the regular season we'll
have more on the game and head over to
t-mobile arena where kevin martin is
hanging out medieval maniacs will be
heading to socal this week brian you've
got your day planner out and plan ahead
all right chris thank you next up the
golden knights travel to la for a royal
rumble with the kings then it's back
home for three games starting next
wednesday with the saint louis blues